bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission dans laquelle nous allons vous
parler de l'économie réelle et non pas
de l'économie fantasmé par nos
dirigeants
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ces
caches une émission consacrée cette
semaine aux énergies gaz électricité
carburant les prix continuent
d'augmenter et alourdissent les factures
d'où vient cette flambée jusqu'où les
prix peuvent-ils encore grimper les
mesures mises en place par le
gouvernement vont elles être efficace
pour pallier les problèmes de pouvoir
d'achat on va en parler dans cette
émission avec olivier delamarche bonjour
olivier bonjour face à vous fini que la
meilleure bonjour vous êtes expert
énergie bienvenue financer cash bonjour
estelle nouvelle hausse de 12,6 pour
cent pour les prix du gaz au 1er octobre
du côté des carburants ce n'est pas
mieux le sans plomb 95 a connu un
nouveau record la semaine dernière avec
une augmentation de 0,2 centime selon
les chiffres communiqués par le
ministère de la transition écologique
quant à l'électricité qu'il faut aussi
s'attendre à des factures alourdi en
février prochain le tarif réglementé
devrait augmenter de 10% selon
l'association ufc que choisir tous les
détails avec le tiroir cash d'antoine
d'assas
[Musique]
on n'avait pas vu ça depuis longtemps
depuis plusieurs semaines les prix de
l'énergie explose le montant des
factures de gaz a augmenté de près de
50% depuis le début de l'année ceux de
l'électricité se diriger il ya peu vers
une hausse de 10 à 15% d'ici février le
sans plomb 95 a pris 25% sur un an le
gazole 30% mais en octobre le
gouvernement a sorti l'artillerie lourde
à coups de chèque énergie pour 5,8
millions de ménages de primes
anti-inflation 200 euros pour 30
millions de français et le gel des prix
du gaz d'abord durant l'hiver puis
finalement jusqu'à fin 2022 ne lésinant
pas sur les moyens financiers car le
coût total de ces mesures dépasse les 11
milliards d'euros et si l'exécutif en a
fait une de ses plus grosses
préoccupations de cette fin d'année
ce n'est pas sans raison car les prix de
l'énergie ou des carburants c'est un
sujet sensible
rappelez-vous 2018 et il est gilet jaune
le point de départ des manifestations
c'était justement le prix des carburants
et l'instauration d'une nouvelle taxe
et pour emmanuel macron lee gilet jaune
c'est un peu comme la casa des papes
elle
mieux vaut s'arrêter à la saison 1
surtout si on veut se faire réélire s'il
a choisi pour le moment la stratégie du
carnet de chèques qu'elle calme
temporairement les esprits peut être
jusqu'à l'élection présidentielle qui
s'est pas sûr qu'elle tienne
éternellement car si les prix continuent
de monter au point de franchir ce fameux
bouclier tarifaire du gouvernement il
faudra envisager des solutions sur le
long terme une baisse des taxes ce
peut-être sur le prix du gaz un quart
par dans les poches de l'état sur les
carburants c'est plus de la moitié
messieurs pour commencer on va revenir
sur les causes de cette flambée des prix
olivier vous comment est-ce que vous
l'expliquer ou pour beaucoup de beaucoup
de raisons il n'y a pas une seule raison
il ya un petit des redémarrages
après après une longue un long gant
fermement donc
vous avez aussi une énorme des
organisations de beaucoup de choses et
puis vous avez des choses beaucoup plus
structurelle qui sont ceux qu'on a fait
vis-à-vis
de l'oléoduc russe et
en essayant de
de taper dessus et 1 et 2 et de faire en
sorte qu' il ne soit jamais en fonction
et puis vous avez aussi tout ce qui est
déversée c'est-à-dire tout ce qui est le
quantitative easing qui fait que ces
matières premières la qui sont des
matières premières cotées en bourse et
donc vous avez des hausse phénoménale
sur c'est sur ces matières premières
pourquoi tout simplement parce qu'il ya
de l'argent qui est mis à disposition
des banques et que ces banques jouent
dessus au même titre qu'elle joue sur
les actions au même titre qu'elle joue
sur le bitcoin au même titre qu'elle
joue sur tous les actifs sur lesquels
ils peuvent aller se porter et vous avez
ces différentes choses qui font monter
les cours de 2
de l'énergie donc y'a rien de nouveau
sous le soleil vous avez en ce qui
concerne l'électricité aussi des règles
européennes qui font que le
l'électricité est indexé sur les sur sur
des prix qui montent eux aussi et donc
vous avez forcément des des variations à
la hausse importante et puis vous avez
ce que vous venez de de raconter
sur le sur les taxes je rappelle que sur
un 60 de prix de l'essence vous avez 50
sentiment en gros de prix du pétrole
vous avez aucun centime de prix du du de
marges de distribution et vous avez un
euro de deux taxes donc évidemment c'est
un peu c'est un peu se défausser sur sur
la hausse du prix du pétrole il
suffirait de baisser les taxes et vous
n'auriez plus de hausse à ces niveaux là
donc on sait maintenant ils ont choisi
une autre stratégie qui est en gros
d'acheter les voix pour 2000 m2 en
faisant des chaînes on va on va parler
après nicolas meilhan vous êtes d'accord
sur les raisons alors que vous êtes
d'accord sur wii elles sont elles sont
multifactorielles il ya un du côté
structurel en attendant sa diminution de
la disponibilité des énergies peu cher
donc on va chercher des énergies de plus
en plus cher et puis après un facteur
conjoncturel cette fois ci qui lie à la
crise du coc vide est donc belle de
lassus demande suivie d'une hausse est
donc un choc sur les prix mais il faut
faire un petit peu la différence entre
les différentes énergies vous avez le
pétrole elle c'est le sens de l'économie
mondiale c'est l'énergie règne du
transport est aujourd'hui on a les prix
quand même été multipliés par quatre on
est descendu à 20 $ on est à 85 dollars
et c'est un sous jacent a beaucoup de
produits compris dans l'alimentaire donc
quand les prix du pétrole augmentent
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle et
s'explique en grande partie l'inflation
que l'on connaît qu'on le connaît
aujourd'hui maintenant au niveau des
prix du pétrole
on a effectivement un souci
on avait un pic de production qui avait
été passé dans la fin de l'année 2010 on
avait le droit à une petite piqûre de
rab avec le pétrole de schiste aux états
unis mais a priori on arrive à la fin la
piqûre et ils n'ont pas prévu de rappel
donc donc on va commencer à être
contraint sur l'approvisionnement en
pétrole et et ça fait des prix à 85
dollars qui pourraient monter entre 100
et 150 dollars à moyen terme le gaz
naturel c'est un petit peu différent
cette énergie leucan désormais une
énergie mondiale avec le gaz de schiste
américain qui peut circuler en bateaux
comme le pétrole est aujourd'hui coûte
de plus en plus cher à cause de la
transition énergétique pour deux raisons
la première c'est qu'on remplace du
charbon notamment en asie par du gaz
donc la demande augmente fortement en
chine japon corée et y compris en inde
et la seconde en europe c'est qu'on
remplace du nucléaire part du
renouvelable et de gaz et qu'on a aussi
comme un as parlé olivier une taxe
carbone qui va encore surenchéri le coup
l'électricité sur le co2 avec les quotas
ets et donc on a des prix qui explosent
et qu'est ce que ça fait ça autant de
pétrole ça va impacter les gilet jaune
mais particulier autant le gaz ça va
impacter les industriels directement
toutes les grands industriels serveurs
coûte très cher alors que le particulier
est entre guillemets un peu protégés
donc c'est un effet kiss cool plus tard
avec des tarifs tarifs réglementés et
donc on est on est sur 7 il n'y a pas
vraiment de perspectives aujourd'hui
pour que ça pour que ça baisse mais
heureusement est ce qu'on peut parler de
crise du secteur de l'énergie
aujourd'hui c'est pas une crise du
secteur de l'énergie en tant que tel les
boîtes et najdi se porte très bien avec
un prix du pétrole plus élevés c'est une
crise tout court parce que nous si on
n'a plus le sens de l'économie on va
avoir on va avoir un problème on a
besoin de ce sens pour pouvoir faire
croître l'économie rembourser nos dettes
financer nos systèmes sociaux et c'est
donc la contrainte sur la disponibilité
de pétrole elle entraîne beaucoup de
problèmes derrière alors conséquences de
la montée des prix de l'énergie de
nombreux problèmes liés au pouvoir
d'achat en france le gouvernement
cci du sujet le 15 septembre l'exécutif
a décidé d'attribuer aux 5,8 millions de
ménages bénéficiaires du chèque énergie
2021 un chèque supplémentaire
exceptionnelle de 100 euros le 30
septembre alors que le la ministre de la
transition écologique barbara pompe il y
annonçait une hausse des tarifs
réglementés de l'électricité aux
alentours de 12% en février 2022 jean
castex le soir même été au jt de tf1 il
a annoncé la création de ce que
l'exécutif appelle un bouclier tarifaire
ensuite le 21 octobre le gouvernement a
dévoilé la création d'une indemnité
inflation de 100 euros à destination de
ceux qui gagnent moins de 2000 euros net
par mois avant de regarder en détail
notamment le fameux bouclier tarifaire
on en est en 3 annonce en deux mois
c'est des annonces qui concerne des
coups de pouce au pouvoir d'achat
olivier est ce que ça signifie
concrètement cas par redonner un peu de
marge au pouvoir d'achat l'exécutif est
complètement impuissant face à la hausse
les prix nommé
c'est le pouce de la main de qui la
mince la main de l'état si vous vous
laissez nous donc ce que on vous donne
c'est qu'on le prend dans vos poches
aussi donc c'est juste c'est juste de
l'habillage c'est juste c'est ce que je
vous disais de la chatte noire qui
appartient cette l'habillage il
sait surtout que c'est surtout qu'ils
s'y prend comme un manche safa ici prend
comme un manche non parce que le but
c'est de réellement d'acheter des voix
donc il faut qu'il fasse quelque chose
de visible et baisser une taxe ça n'est
pas visible parce que finalement vous
allez ça va être compensée par une
hausse due d'autres choses et donc ça
n'est pas visible en revanche vous
envoyez un chèque c'est visible et donc
c'est pour ça qu'ils font qui font ça
comme ça mais quand vous mettez un
bouclier par exemple sur le sur les prix
d'une d'une énergie ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que vous compensez vis-à-vis
des industriels
c'est à dire que vous leur payer le prix
et vous payer la différence
vous bloquer le prix donc qui paye c'est
bien nous au final l'état c'est nous
enfin il faudrait vraiment que les gens
se met ça dans la tête parce que l'état
vous fait des cadeaux les tenants l'état
il vous fait pas de cadeau l'état c'est
nous donc on se fait des cadeaux à nous
mêmes et quand on quand on nous donne un
chèque c'est pas quelqu'un de
l'extérieur qui nous donne un chèque
c'est nous qui nous donnons un chèque
quand on s'endette quand l'état
s'endette c'est nous qui nous endettons
donc il faudrait sortir de cette espèce
de dialectique où on vous enfume en
permanence en vous disant val et à
regarder il fait il fait quelque chose
pour le pouvoir d'achat non il ne fait
rien pour le pouvoir d'achat parce que
il va bien piqué cet argent quelque part
et le quelque part c'est nous mais si on
va marquer une courte pause on vient
dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine la
flambée des prix de l'énergie et pour en
parler nous sommes en plateau avec
nicolas meilleurs experts énergie si
nicolas mais lyon va regarder en quoi
consiste exactement le fameux bouclier
tarifaire c'est un dispositif grâce
auquel je suis tu il n'y aura plus
d'augmentation des prix du gaz et ce à
partir de novembre un gel donc des
tarifs réglementés du gaz et une
limitation à 4 % du tarif réglementé de
l'électricité début 2022 c'est un bon
outil selon vous face à une hausse
structurelle des des coûts de
l'électricité
je pense qu on est on est sur des
rustines en fait on est toujours sur des
rustines destine à 11,4 milliards
d'euros destiné aux buts 4 milliard
d'euros ssl c'est là où je suis un petit
peu plus nuancé qu'oliver c'est qu'il
faut reconnaître au moins que le
gouvernement a pris il n'a pas attendu
six mois avant de faire un chèque j'ai
les jaunes ils ont 15 milliards au bout
de six mois x me x x week-end là ils ont
fait le chèque direct pour probablement
qui est un petit timing par rapport à
l'élection présidentielle mais le
problème c'est que ça ne résoud ça ne
résout pas le problème c'est le décale
si vous regardez les débats sur la
transition énergétique dans le grand
débat qui a été organisé par le mentor
de manuel macron françois hollande le
mot pétrole apparaît deux fois en six
cents pages qu'est ce qu'ils font pour
baisser notre consommation de pétrole
rien qu'est-ce qu'ils ont annoncés rien
donc on dit juste on va donner de
l'argent aux gens petit à petit donc on
arrive à ce que qu'on appelle le money
l'argent hélicoptères on va juste
distribuer notre on va se redit ce
tribut et notre argent et jusqu'au jour
où ça s'écroule voilà
mes mais concrètement ce ne sont pas des
solutions c'est des rustines en vue
d'une élection présidentielle qui
permettra au président peut-être de se
maintenir olivier on l'a vu à dans le
terroir cash sur le prix du gaz un quart
par dans les poches de l'état sur les
carburants c'est plus de la moitié ce
sont donc des produits qui sont très
taxée est-ce que plutôt que de donner
des aides des deux fers de donner des
russes temps de mettre des rustines
comme le disait nicolas milan et ce
qu'il faudrait pas plutôt parce que la
solution ne se retrouverait pas plutôt
dans la baisse des taxes mais c'est ce
que je vous ai dit me metaxas eux c'est
moins frappant pour les gens que de
recevoir un chèque donc donc on préfère
se se toute façon c'est un espèce de
circuit fermé si vous voulez donc vous
avez des taxes donc on vous pompe les
les les taxes et et il en faut
aujourd'hui beaucoup pour payer toutes
les bêtises qu'on a faites donc il faut
vraiment essayer de taxer au maximum et
c'est ce qu'ils font et puis de l'autre
côté on va on va très probablement faire
de nouveau emprunts donc on va se
retrouver avec un déficit budgétaire
encore hallucinant pour donc des impôts
futurs pour vous redonner de l'argent
mais c'est vous qui ça sort de votre
poche ça revient dans votre poche c'est
donc et en général ça revient de façon
beaucoup plus petit que ça n'est sorti
donc voilà c'est un jeu de bonneteau si
vous voulez baisser les taxes ne peut
plus passer par une baisse de taxes et
un transfert de taxes éventuellement
vite ou les baisses là on les augmente
qui parle vous le dire on vous dit pas
où mais ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut
quand même savoir en france tout gens le
savent mais c'est qu'on est le seul pays
au monde à avoir une taxe sur la taxe un
puisque sur le pétrole vous avez à dire
une taxe sur la taxe vous avez là tu es
icpe la taxe carbone qui va impacter le
prix du pétrole et après vous avez la
tva sur cet axe donc c'est quand même un
exploit taxe sur la taxe et on attend
peut-être un jour la taxe sur la taxe
sur la taxe peut-être qu'on y viendra un
jour s'ils ont trop baisser les taxes
copains et quand vous dites nicolas
meilhan que les mesures prises par le
gouvernement des cales le problème
qu'est ce qu'est ce que comment le
résoudre ce problème selon vous ce
problème et le résoudre de plusieurs
façons on regarde là où on consomme du
pétrole beaucoup dans les voitures dans
les maisons aussi on réduit on remplace
les chaudières à fuel par des chaudières
qui marque peut-être à l'électricité
peut-être demain avec des réacteurs des
réacteurs nucléaires c'était le cas
aujourd'hui dans les voitures bars on
bat des voitures peut être un tout petit
peu plus petit peut-être qu'on essaie
d'inciter les gens à rentrer à deux dans
leur voiture à faire du covoiturage il
ya beaucoup de solutions qui existent
qui ment juste c'est le courage pour
mettre en place son nez puis sur des
problèmes d des solutions en termes de
modes de consommation finalement il faut
il faut adapter enfin il faut être juste
pragmatique on pense qu'ils consomment
du pétrole et puis on réduit la
consommation c'est très facile il ya il
ya un ingénieur et l'ingénieur un peu
génie de l'industrie automobile qui
s'appelle jean albert grégoire qui après
les chocs pétroliers en 70 sont 75 à 10
il faudra mettre en place il faudrait
transférer la fiscalité pour passer
d'une fiscalité sur les chevaux à une
fiscalité sur le poids aujourd'hui on
pourrait faire ça pour faire évoluer la
fiscalité pas rajouter de nouvelles
taxes pour encourager des produits
qu'ils consomment moins de pétrole voilà
tout simplement nous avons à gérer une
bosse a résumé le premier ministre en
parlant de la situation actuelle olivier
peut-on être certain que la hausse des
prix ne sera pas durable et est-ce
réellement une bosse
c'est une grosse bosse on va dire
keith harris de se finir en plateau
mais très au dessus donc le nom le
problème si vous voulez cesser ce que
dit nicolas c'est que si vous mettez des
rustines vous pouvez pas vous attendre à
régler le problème donc
il faut vraiment une stratégie et là on
s'aperçoit que ya pas de stratégie il
suffisait d'écouter monsieur macro hier
et monsieur macron qui nous annonce
victorieusement qu'il va lancer la
construction de 3 ou 4 p r je ne sais
plus il me semblait que c'était 4 et que
ça a diminué à 3 mais enfin bon je peux
peut-être me tromper
mais en attendant on ferme en ferme
fessenheim donc on voit bien qu'il ya
pas de stratégie avec la hausse des prix
olivier vallet réagir vite mais réagir
vite quand vous construisez un ne perd
ses 10 ans et 15 ans donc c'était avant
qu'il fallait se poser la question et
pas juste parce que dans six mois il ya
une élection c'est pas c'est pas là
qu'il faut commencer à se poser des
questions c'est pas quand les matières
premières explosent à la hausse qu'il
faut se poser la question c'est avant
le le connaissait le mot gouverner c'est
prévoir
mais c'est pas seulement prévoir sa
réélection c'est prévoir tout court
d'ailleurs dix ans si on se projette dix
ans en arrière on est en 2012 les
questions de françois hollande sur une
promesse de baisser le nucléaire donc si
le candidat hollande élu grâce aux
écolos avaient plutôt prévu de
construire à nos pères on pourrait
inaugurer demain demain donc on a perdu
dix ans et les gens ont oublié ce qui
s'est passé qu'est-ce qu'ils occupent et
françois hollande sa première année les
prix du pétrole pourquoi on était à plus
de 100 dollars il a ajouté des pieds et
des mains pour baisser la marge de
distribution
parce qu'il n'a pas le contrôle des
puits de pétrole et pour réduire la
marge de total et c'est cela ma rue
tréfilerie chinois les quinze santis
était déjà une réussite elle n'avait pas
les vigiles à chaque fois que ça remonte
on remet des rustines mais on ne résout
pas le problème et on a perdu dix ans
elle est durable aujourd'hui cette
hausse des prix
alors si vous voulez si vous avez demain
une crise financière majeure ou un
qu'ovide qu'un variant des états plus
qui plombe toute l'économie les prix
vont à nouveau baissé mais
structurellement bien évidemment que ça
reviendra ça reviendra à ses niveaux et
je rappelle que le maximum d'extraction
de pétrole a été passé en novembre 2018
c'était déjà il ya trois ans et
aujourd'hui il n'est pas sûr qu'on
repasse ce point là donc cela voudrait
dire que le pic pétrolier a eu à ce
moment là ça va être très compliqué de
faire croître des économies avec moins
de pétrole
elle des mesures qui ont un coût pour
l'état on lundi 11 4 milliards d'euros
c'est le coût total de la facture pour
le gouvernement on l'a dit olivier
l'énergie c'est un sujet explosif on se
souvient du mouvement des gilet jaune
qui a débuté avec l'instauration pardon
de la fameuse taxe carbone sur les
carburants pour résumer en gros selon
vous est ce que ces aides c'est quoi
c'est acheter la paix sociale un peu
assez acheter la paix sociale s'est
acheté des bulletins de vote etc etc je
le répète ça ne coûte pas au
gouvernement
ça ne coûte pas à l'état ça coûte à nous
à c'est-à-dire connaissez la phrase de
de monsieur hollande justement puisqu'on
en parle tu disais ah bah ça coûte rien
c'est l'état qui paye et mais l'état je
vous rappelle que ce c'est nous c'est
collectivement c'est nous donc ça nous
coûte de l'argent c'est ce plan nous
coûte énormément d'argent pour une
rustine donc bon on dresse ici les gens
sont heureux de payer des milliards et
des milliards pour des rustines ça les
regarde mais il devrait y penser au
moment où il met un bulletin de vote
dans l'urne nicolas meilhan un dernier
mot sur la près on l'a dit grâce au
bouclier tarifaires les prix du gaz par
exemple ne devrait pas augmenter en 2022
sur le front du gua justement dès 2023
les consommateurs devrait le payer un
peu plus cher que les cours du marché de
sorte que les sommes non payées en 2022
soit récupéré par l les opérateurs de
gaz mais pas question de faire payer
tout la facture aux consommateurs une
partie sera payé par le budget de l'état
d'ici là c'est vrai que sur scène
c'est
selon par les consommateurs mais une
fois plus que le vrai sujet sur le gaz
et des industriels les industriels pour
qui ça coûte très très cher qui n'ont
pas justement tous ces mécanismes de
protection
de la part de l'état sur sur ces prix là
c'est ça qui est vraiment beaucoup plus
inquiétant qui va mettre à mal beaucoup
d'entreprises qui consomment énormément
énormément d'énergie donc bon je préfère
pas commenter sur ses prix du gas tu as
que ci est fait à chaque fois depuis 20
ans et on voit que ça ne fonctionnait
pas de toute façon et le pire dans ce
problème c'est qu'en fait c'est une
situation dans laquelle on se met tout
seul si vous voulez parce que
aujourd'hui le prix du gaz il augmente
aussi en europe pourquoi pour des
raisons géopolitiques monsieur poutine a
besoin de la validation de son deuxième
'pipeline' que l'europe l'allemagne
rechigne à l'est et donc on arrive en
situation divers avec des réservoirs de
gaz qui sont plus bas comme ce n'est
jamais arrivé monsieur poutine dit
qu'ils valaient remplir tout le monde ya
merci monsieur poutine c'est gentil bon
en fait qu'il ne remplit pas donc là les
prix sont repartis à la hausse donc on a
choisi
alors que la russie fait un tiers de
notre gaz un tir de pétrole vouloir
absolument acheter plutôt du gaz de
schiste de monsieur biden trump
sauf que ce gaz de schiste 10 de moins
en moins disponible et donc on sait
organiser nous-mêmes notre contrainte
c'est nous qui l'avons choisi s'être
cette hausse des prix c'est nous qui
l'avons choisi et c'est nous que l'on la
paix merci beaucoup nicolas à meilhan
d'avoir été parmi nous dans cette
émission je rappelle que vous êtes
expert énergie olivier c'est l'heure des
questions et commentaires cash
et on démarre avec la question de
guillaume favier à quand une vraie
politique industrielle en france avec la
suppression pure et simple des taxes sur
la production et la revalorisation des
filières techniques et manuels un pays
et sa population ne peuvent être riches
dans la durée qu avec une
industrialisation poussée je suis
d'accord et je pose la même question à
quand je ne sais pas en face à celle de
jacques auzou r le poids qu'il en coûte
seat vitam aeternam mais je ne vois pas
où est le problème c'est juste la nature
de l'économie qui change tant que ça
marche qu'est ce que vous voulez et
c'est que ça marche pas le quoi qu'il en
coûte ça veut rien dire c'est
ses menottes
c'est encore une phrase si vous voulez
comme ce que je vous disais à l'instant
où je vous disais
l'état c'est nous qui payons donc le
quoi qu'il en coûte ça veut dire que
vous avez des transferts en fait
d'argent mais que le la masse d'argent
elle est la même on vous la pique dans
votre poche et on vous dit ah ben on
protège le consommateur
oui d'accord mais vous êtes aussi
consommateur et pour le protéger c'est
pas le budget de l'état le budget de
l'état ça veut rien dire le budget de
l'état c'est nous donc eh bien là c'est
pareil donc ça ne marche pas et on le
voit bien parce que ça veut dire que on
vous branche une perf et qu'on ne peut
plus jamais la retirer mais cette perf
là elle ne vous guérit pas elle ne vous
sauf pas elle donne l'apparence que vous
êtes encore vivant c'est tout mais c'est
quand même pas très réjouissant de vivre
dans une économie en étant mort mais en
faisant semblant d'être vivant donc je
suis pas sûr que ce soit souhaitable
merci maintenant chacun y voit voit midi
à sa porte merci olivier c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain rendez vous la semaine
prochaine en attendant n'oubliez pas de
poser toutes vos questions sur les
réseaux sociaux à olivier delamarche
avec le hashtag rt cash on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine et on skate avec
votre dernier mot les bains en fait
l'état c'est un espèce de bonneteau
permanent